We Begin the day with the war in Ukraine
according to Vladimir Putin today in
Moscow in a rare partly unscripted
public discussion Russian President
Putin attacked the West accusing it of
using the military and money to
undermine Russia's national security and
its International standing Putin accused
the U.S and its European allies of
fueling the war in Ukraine he doubled
down on his commitment to securing the
donbass region in eastern Ukraine and
still referring to the invasion as a
special military operation Putin went
down the list of reasons for the
conflict but there was a noticeable
Omission Putin said nothing about his
goal of cleansing Ukraine of its
neo-nazis
he also made it clear who qualifies now
as an ally to Russia topping the list
China which has declared a No Limits
partnership with Russia and there is
also something personal here for Putin
as well the day he called Chinese
president Xi Jinping a close friend
here is part of what Vladimir Putin said
today he begins by lashing out at the
West
the historical period of undivided
dominance of the western world affairs
is coming to an end the unipolar world
is becoming a thing of the past we stand
at a historical Frontier
after all quite recently
we thought that we were turning into a
semi-colony
we could not do anything without our
Western Partners
we can't make Financial calculations
we won't have Technologies
we won't have markets
all you have to do is click and
everything falls apart
but no nothing fell apart and the
fundamental foundations of the existence
of the Russian Federation turned out to
be much stronger than someone thought
about it maybe we ourselves thought
[Music]
well my first guest tonight is Bill
Browder he's the CEO of Hermitage
capital and is also head of the global
magnitsky Justice campaign bill is
considered an authority on all things
Vladimir Putin bill it's good to see you
again I want to get your take on on some
of the things we heard today Putin said
today that Russia stands for
multi-polarity and for Traditional
Values
who was he speaking to today and I dare
say that his intended audience may not
have been sitting right there before him
in Moscow
uh definitely not so so um his audience
is actually sitting or his his hopes for
audience uh is sitting in America and so
basically if Vladimir Putin is in a very
tough spot right now because he's losing
the war
um he's losing the war primarily because
the ukrainians have been fighting so
well and also primarily because he's the
the ukrainians have been getting a huge
amount of military support from the
United States of America and of course
Western Europe but if if Putin can
somehow convince the United States not
to support Ukraine then he'll be in a
position where he can actually win the
war and so what is he doing right now
he's trying to um reach out to the
Grassroots of the far right in America
in hopes that in 2024
um with the next presidential election
uh there will be a Groundswell of
support not to have Ukraine be funded by
him America and so this is kind of a
almost a Hail Mary if you will because
he's doing so badly in the war
well there is this concern in the U.S if
Republicans win control of Congress in
the midterm elections next month that
that will be the beginning of the end of
of this incredible U.S military support
for Ukraine how much would you say that
Putin is counting on this GOP
um grenade to explode on Capitol Hill
come November
well it says
it's his only hope really because he
can't win the war militarily at the
moment um he's lost 65 000 troops
according to the ukrainians he's lost a
lot of territory he's taken the people
he's replaced are not experienced
soldiers they're getting bombed by uh
ukrainians using Western Equipment
and so he really is in a he's he's
really playing dice now he's just hoping
and praying that he can somehow make the
U.S not support him and I I don't think
that in the end I mean I think that
there's been a few words spoken by Uh
Kevin McCarthy but on the on the
Republican side Mitch McConnell is
directly contradicting Kevin McCarthy
and so
I I don't think that America is going to
pull out of their support for Ukraine
but that is Putin's only desperate hope
right now and you know for the first
time a majority of Russians say that
they favor opening peace talks with
Ukraine that is according to a poll by
The Independent lavada Center
um the greatest support for this is
among young adults who also happen to
oppose Putin's mobilization of
reservists the most did you see these
Trends reflected in any of Putin's
comments today
but Putin says he's open for negotiation
but the only problem with his
negotiation that he's open for is he
wants to negotiate to say that he gets
all the Ukrainian territory that he's
already occupied that's not negotiable
and so so everything that he's um I mean
he's now sounding like kind of a weak
desperate man saying he wants to
negotiate and getting various proxies to
say that there should be negotiation and
and getting people to criticize Ukraine
saying they're not negotiating of course
they're not negotiating on the terms
that he set out that the terms that that
should be negotiated are a full
withdrawal of Russia from Ukraine and of
course that's not even on the table as
far as Putin is concerned and Vladimir
Putin um today we saw this again he
continues to shower Chinese president Xi
Jinping with words of affection but this
often seems to be something like an
unrequited love uh Putin looking less
like a Russian Bearer and more like a
panda bear do you know can you explain
what what's going on here
well so when before this war started
Putin was in Beijing with the Xi Jinping
at the Olympics and he he probably
whispered in in Gigi Ping's ear
um this is going to be a three-day War
we're going to humiliate America and the
West this is all going to be great
um and it's turned out to be an
eight-month war and and um he's been the
one humiliated and prices of oil and gas
have gone up for China and and it hasn't
been this this uh friendship forever
thing that Putin has hoped for it's not
like Chinese companies are going in to
Russia because they don't want to be
sanctioned in the west and it's not like
China has done a whole lot of anything
other than buying a bit of discounted
Russian oil and so this is kind of as
you say unrequited love Putin is is
trying to put that out there in in the
same kind of desperate way as he's
trying to reach out to the far right in
America hoping that that somebody is
going to come to his Aid because he's
suffering right now he's flailing yeah
the far right in America and then Xi
Jinping in Beijing wow those are two
opposite ends of the spectrum there that
he's trying to work Bill Browder is
always good talking with you we
appreciate your time and your insights
tonight thank you
thank you
the new U.S defense strategy published
today highlights China as the greatest
strategic security threat for America
now the 80-page document lays out the
Chinese threat and then outlines what a
future U.S military response should be
China may be the 21st century Nemesis of
the west but right now Russia continues
to get in the way
here's the U.S defense secretary Lloyd
Alston on the national defense strategy
known as the NDS
at the same time the NDS bluntly
describes Russia
as an acute threat
and we chose the word acute carefully
unlike China Russia can't systemically
challenge the United States over the
long term
but Russian aggression
does pose an immediate and sharp threat
to our interests and values
I want to bring in Bradley Bowman now
he's senior director of the center on
Military and political power at the
foundation for the defense of
democracies Bradley it's good to see you
again secretary Alston saying that
Russia is only an acute threat I mean
that that sounds a little bit it smacks
a little bit of Barack Obama's assertion
that Russia is only a regional power is
that is that the message that you're
hearing
thanks for the opportunity to join you
and thanks for the question you know the
uh uh it's important to know that the
original draft of the national defense
strategy that was released today was
done before February 24th and then
reality as it often does intervene uh
and it had to be largely Rewritten and
so we find ourselves with words like
acute being attributed to the threat
from Russia and the pacing challenge or
pacing threat for China the bottom line
here is any strategy worth its name
tries to coordinate ends and means
America's means are extensive but
they're not unlimited so we have to
allocate finite resources so you have
this Administration I'd say laudably
establishing priorities any strategy
that doesn't establish priorities really
isn't a strategy and they're saying very
clearly that China is the number one
threat more so than Russia and the
primary logic behind that from their
perspective and I think it stands up to
Merit to scrutiny is that uh the
relative economic power of China when
you combine the Hostile ideology and
economy roughly this eyes of the United
States and a military modernization
effort uh never seen in the history of
the People's Republic of China that all
comes together to constitute a threat
unlike anything the United States has
seen in modern history and as serious as
the Russia threat is the threat from the
People's Republic of China is more
serious that's what the Biden
Administration is saying and I think
they're right on that secretary Alston
today was asked yet again about the the
nuclear threat posed by Russia and he
said again that he sees no sign that
Russia is preparing to use nuclear
weapons I'm wondering you and I we've
spoken about this before are we playing
into Putin's Playbook here by amplifying
this threat simply by talking about it
so much
you know uh the essence of deterrence is
trying to affect the thinking of your
adversary so they do or don't do what
what you want and Putin is clearly
throughout this uh this Invasion since
February 24th has been rattling his new
nuclear saber to try to impact uh the
actions of Ukraine the United States and
our European allies uh they're
conducting a another nuclear test
recently it was fairly standard but in
the context of the invasion of Ukraine
and Putin's comments it's concerning I
think we have no choice to talk about it
but I think the Bible instruction has
handled it roughly right delivering as
far as I can tell very serious messages
behind the scenes while being relatively
cool in public and saying there would be
catastrophic consequences but not being
too specific I think that's about the
right move Ukraine's president zielinski
today described Russian efforts to
capture the eastern city of bakmut as
crazy given the the high cost of this
attack
um and the little strategic value that
the city presents
um what do you make of a Russian
strategy at the moment
you know the the Russians have been uh
getting pummeled uh and have been uh
we've seen them getting routed and and
in in serious Retreat and the more we
learn about the state of their forces uh
it's just uh not good at all and all the
momentum has been with Ukrainian forces
is because of their agility the skill
the Western weapons that are being
provided and and the high morale and so
a Putin you know annexed these quote
unquote Annex these four regions uh even
as his forces didn't control all of them
and were Retreat and that's a very
awkward thing for Putin as he's trying
to make this look more successful than
it really is and engender fleeting
support within Russia and so there's
been this tension between Putin at the
political level and as military leaders
as military leaders are saying we have
to do an organized Retreat we're getting
pummeled here if we don't it's going to
look like what we've seen around kharkiv
and yet Putin didn't want that so you
have the Wagner group in there trying to
be more successful and so there's an
interest on Wagner's part to show more
success but the bottom line is this is
just a distraction I'd say the overall
narrative continues and that is momentum
on the Ukrainian side
Bradley Bowman with the foundation for
the defense of democracies Bradley as
always we appreciate your time valuable
analysis tonight thank you
thank you